yo it's wild 94 one-man bootleg cab we
on the bus right now we've got to the
man of the hour this to sold-out ratibor
probably the hottest artists on the
planet right now
his name is Bryson tiller trying to
figure out how that works now is Dee
carding thank you for all of them that's
Mike is amazing he's looking at like you
really own your yeah we try man 8
congratulations on everything bro like I
first saw you uh I was backstage at the
Travis show you guys had back-to-back
sold-out shows in Boston
yeah at House of Blues yeah and I I felt
like I that was when I first really
realized how real the way was because
obviously that wasn't you or that wasn't
your show and the crowd was lit knew
every word Wow exactly
uh I was i I remember when I was when we
first opened up from the first time I
vote for our forum I was like worried
that nobody was going on my music right
now went out there like it was a good 50
people in I didn't who I was you know me
and I was tight and I was just crazy to
see the growth you know me like now like
and then when I started touring with a
more like like you see at the Boston
show everybody know everything um talk
about though like just where you are
right now man I feel like um lately like
every artist that really gets moving
like you get the the the quintessential
Justin Bieber Kylie Jenner cosign and I
saw you got that but but how do you feel
like like has it hit you how big you are
yet I mean it's moving very fast not
really not yet you know man it's still
like kind of just building up still
building up um talk about eight your uh
your video game swag man I just saw you
put on Instagram that should be a saint
in trays for the 20th time no Chico yeah
I was trying to here's the thing about
the the new Xbox one Xbox 360 right it
was like my game wouldn't save like I
don't know everything my games are
saving but whenever I go get tattoos and
stuff on my cjm I do yeah and then like
work out like I say my god I turn it off
and they come back and they're all gone
everything's going I'm just like but my
story is still there like last way so I
just stopped playing I was like I'm not
doing it and I saw you were on the Super
Smash Brothers heavy which one of my
favorite games of all time all day all
day man what what is um if you had to
rank like your top two or three games of
all time what
okay GTA being number one of course
which specific GTA just any of I mean
you know you know what I'm gonna say San
Andreas San Andreas okay Clark I want to
hear me say that because you know GTA 5
is definitely i'ma just say senators
because it just like change the game
sure did hell yeah it was like no GTA 3
change the game but San Andreas is made
race made it likes it was so hip-hop
like it was you felt like you were like
it was like you know menace to society
but yeah yeah exactly and that's what I
love they do a lot with most of their
video games like I feel like they do
they take like a movie or short I about
it and didn't make a whole story around
I think it's made what else
Oh number two um number two have to be
or something I just play all the time I
want to say a rockstar game but I feel
red dead redemption used to be my
Redemption is dope but I'm about to put
bully over I was gonna say I was allowed
to say slept on rockstar game is bully I
swear I put bully over read their holy
was fire bully was though you have like
a rock star notice you show a lot of the
rocks I think a you get a little missile
rock star check on the side uh I wish
every crazy think I have you as an
unlockable character in the next GTA
that would be amazing
actually I would be corny but yeah I
would want to have something to do that
was TJ for sure for sure
um you you've shouted out a lot of your
influences randomly soldier boy was one
of them yeah I'm curious though like
when you were coming up what was like
your favorite like top two or three
albums you think they that kind of
formed who you are as an artist I've
heard you say omarion's Oh al boom but
like what were the two like if you were
to have to be on an island tomorrow and
they were my yo you got to take two or
three albums with you which which ones
are those imma take confessions amazing
classic
I think I'm gonna take I gotta take a
dream album over there
yo dream is incredible my favorite him
in D'Angelo my two favorite R&B artists
oh yeah there's a little crazy Angeles
Fire for sure oh I gotta take a dream
Bob I'm just not sure which one it's
hard but on the third will probably
probably be
day that's hard hard question for
someone pick a hip problem I'm just I'm
probably gonna pick another R&B one and
say uh it is our question I'm over just
take it like I pick our three by one um
you you have a picture with Kylie on the
gram if you got to meet Kanye and vibe
with the with easy at all no I never got
I never met time I feel like everybody
who's on that damn notepad that keeps
putting on Instagram I feel like you
deserve a spot on everybody on that damn
anyways um I had how how much have you
been participating in writing for other
artists because obviously your pen
griffey and your pen game is so strong
thanks man and right now you are that
dude thank you and I'm sure that the the
inquiries are coming like crazy yeah
have you have you gotten in and records
are shot any references for anybody not
not yet uh like I said I only wrote one
song it was Chris Brown but like I'm
working on some more stuff like I really
didn't focus on my music but like I'm
ready to get back in the studio start
dishing them out you know um as far as
your music I see traps holes out of here
bro it's like it is super out of here
it's an amazing project front to back
album mixtape whatever you want to call
it it's been on the iTunes charts for
like since it came out as Jeezy would
say it's sitting on the charts like a
beach chair the chart type of booster
yes is a gz line but um I'm curious uh
the next projects I feel like we're just
starting to get to know you as an artist
as a person like like are you already
working on new music yeah I started on
some new stuff last time I was LA so you
you already have the ball rolling for
the new stuff yeah got to marry my boy I
always actually shout out to ayo the
wreckage up put out on soundcloud was
fire that's a laptop he's across the way
overall yeah uh anyways yeah he was like
home he just playing some pizzas right
so got me excited to get back in the
studio how hard is it being a father cuz
I got a son how hard is it being a
father living this lifestyle it's the
hardest thing elbowroom
cuz I saw you saying you miss out on
some milestones and stuff yeah it's hard
super FaceTime gotta be clutch yeah V
was she not a FaceTime me from my oppas
crazy like she has a little outfit that
she like learner's on and stuff and
she bass us a saber as a contact and I
discipline her daughter she's - she's -
have you I took her on the road at all I
know
no yeah I keep her away from all that
had she seen you live I'm sure so far um
and she been to ashemark she's going to
like my last show on a tour I told them
that wouldn't I would never burn her
I'll never bring her on a tour bus and
talking aboard - like how magical she
has her own area I don't have my own
entire tour bus you know me like you're
sharing it right now yet you Shanna with
the girl boys yeah and one day you'll be
like yo this is mine the crew got there
I always wanted this type experience
that's why I was kind of like yeah I am
living yo and I'm not gonna lie this is
probably the roomiest tour bus I might
have ever been on this is only because
we parked in the stretched out it's very
vivid open would be like is all the time
when you're driving race would it like
the tour I know is is this one of the
tour but you can't take a [__] on any
tour bus right that's like the no-go
that's the mo so you just have to wait
so you hit the gas that way venue I
thought we did pretty good lately
yo girls like we only like six date endo
literally females well I haven't seen
girls cute girls specifically baddest
[__] love you bro and I'm curious
what has been like a moment so far
you're say your six dates in the tour
but so far since you since Travis was
released and you've been as hot as
you've been um has there been a an issue
with a fan or any sort of like person
just taking it too far that you could
share with us maybe someone finding out
where your cells at and I we I had not
occurred you know it's crazy we get more
dudes doing that like really is kind of
like grown ass lately and yeah just
grown as dudes that just like come to
Aries show every shot post pictures like
ask for pictures right
and then they'll pose like yeah me and
the bro me and the homie and I kill me -
I'm coming out to the concert - [__]
like hahaha I I get out that's crazy
who's been somebody who's reached out to
you as a fan um obviously you know I saw
you kicking it with ASAP I saw you
kicking it with Justin and the weekend
and everybody but somebody who's who you
know is a fan of yours or someone that's
reached out that you've kind of been
kind of starstruck like damn like that
dude knows who I am and is vibing to me
good right Drake of course and and you
almost like Drake tried signing you
which is crazy
yeah when it comes to working with with
like somebody like Timbaland - who I
heard is I know a couple of the homies
who are part of
Timbo but Timberlane I feel like guys
like Tim Landry all these dudes they
have like a very meticulous process when
they're making music what I mean just
like as far as like you know how like
Dre or Kanye or how all these dudes it's
like every little thing has to be right
oh yeah
what is it like working with somebody
like Tim in in the studio like is that
honestly he kind of just let me do me to
be honest you know I mean he gave me the
beats I went did my thing you know me
actually he actually suggested a few
changes but I just kept it the way I
wanted to keep it he was cool with the
ants no they did with it they did sorry
not sorry
you know man been that way um was the
killer NSYNC mixtape was that it was
that you know to the video game at all
uh condom I like I like to learn sting
what's your character on there I'm an
orchid saber-tooth this one saying I
liked it but you weren't going on it
like that I mean I barely can remember
what the characters look like I think I
remember the graphics but I remember
killing she was superlative to
understand was I it was is Mortal Kombat
Soul Calibur the Mortal Kombat though
Street Fighter what classic Street
Fighter you know the my favorite games
like to play is like our side scrollers
where you dislike I'm not like like I'll
be like you could play Street Fighter
but you can select those characters and
then just like what an interstitial gang
up about yeah dogs and stuff right
that's the type of games all like plant
like I love adventure game being from
Louisville have you ever actually been
to the Kentucky Derby no that's crazy
right you got a comb I could never
afford to it's a very like I mean my dad
used to be a cameraman for a racetrack
back in the day and that [__] is like
serious and yo but you got now you're
that do other than people to come Derby
just be trying to show off and just be
tipping people like crazy it's like the
old white man version of the strip club
like like the Atlanta strip club is hey
okay come on bet on horses and tip
waiters is like I stay pretty close to
like people were like one apart to
church are like near Churchill Downs and
FA I was like at my like crazy prices
just the own yo um I got my man here
who's Adrian the intern he's the guy who
first put me on to your music before the
album came out and so he's got a
question once I'm asked a question I'm
curious
other than Drake was the most famous
person on yourself alright now just hit
up now I can just hit up the most famous
person
it's gotta be Bieber right I'll have
even though oh okay I'm sure coach
context oh man
Drake I mean what if he was like Beyonce
and just drops the man next question
next question that's crazy
I was crayon got you got you he's like I
don't know I don't know man
alright well look the album is out now
congratulations on everything man is
there gonna be any remixes drop in that
maybe it don't remix sorry nice fabulous
I know do this thing oh sorry not sorry
but there'll be any official remixes in
the works
oh I don't know man I think I'm just
gonna leave it where it is and just
mention to the next you know man
move forward why did you decide to I'm
cure I'm always curious cuz I got a lot
of close friends on RCA
but I'm curious why you know you had an
opportunity to side with Tim you had an
opportunity sound ovo which most young
people would be like oh [__] i can sign
the drake let me do that but why did you
choose RCA um it was like a when I was
younger I made a lot of dumb business
poor choices when it came to like
business and stuff like that and that
was because I didn't have a manager now
you got the homie Neil and I have a
lawyer
right I didn't have you know I mean
other friends who actually care you know
I mean exactly so now I have all that I
was just like we all just came to you
know mean just like it was like a group
decision so I owe this what they told me
that I think this was best for me you
know I mean and like I thought they was
right you know never apparently they
were right man and you know why I'm
curious what is like you're you got a
big like there's like a very mysterious
vibe to Bryson tiller like there's I
haven't seen a video interview with you
yeah like you're just very you know is
that on purpose to mystique out those
person I hate it like being plastered
all over the internet like yeah it
always happens people get over overly uh
you know they they over serve the
marketplace in the people you tired even
on snapchat like I should be kind of
like loose on there just like L videos
blah blah blah but and then I seem like
all of my snapchat videos on some ice
page one time I was like that's kind of
weird
no I'm not doing that again it'll be
like the most random videos when I just
go like down just like why is our video
and me
oh that's alright beaver D challenge you
do a foot race actually what happened
was they came into my dressing room him
and be major you know be major major
ally that's a hit they came into the
dressing room and the last time I seemed
to be major I raced him yeah and uh
somewhere out on La very underrated
writers oh yeah exactly
my career shout out to Pooh Bear shout
out the Pooh Bear I raised some and I
beat him I dusted him of course and uh I
was like man I thought when I saw him I
was like yo you went around to his home
you gonna get this huh the exact and
Justin was like which I talked about was
like nah beat him in a foot race blah
blah blah he said you want a race I said
hot smoking bread on flavor we you know
sense when I say you know he posted that
on Instagram like Brice until enix
and I saw the way was when I was like he
just looked at like your favor gonna get
walk by the dust oh who is there anybody
who can give it to you on the sticks
like famous because I saw you're playing
with like the weekend anybody can [__]
with you on Collin oh where are you are
you kind of that dude I know the game
legit the game is about that [__] all
real yeah the game is series when come
to seem like you only played like he
plays like NBA 2k already mess with the
sports game but but have you had any
issues like in a weekend play games
there's a beef he's a beast on the stick
duty but that was PlayStation like me to
come about turn the Xbox Xbox yeah yeah
we'll see how it gets down you know me
what about arm is there any binge
watching going on on the bus you
watching any like any any TV show would
you [__] wait I've been watching a
code name kids next door I don't know
what that is do you
that's a new wave you know that is Colo
name kid next door was on Netflix I
downloaded all of from iTunes I don't
want to check it out man well look Bryce
until it makes you go see more tour the
merch is lit the show is lit I got to
see you live with Travis I can't wait to
see what you got in store tonight man
and our yeah man shout out to this guy
preciate your time brother
oh man